[Music]
on this Wednesday night the new
recommendation about wearing face masks
in public why advice from Canada's top
doctor has evolved thinking of it as I'm
protecting you and you're protecting me
the childcare crunch for parents and
pleas for help if it's a long history of
politicians thinking childcare is just a
private family responsibility small
business desperate for rent relief why a
federal plan doesn't measure up from
downplaying Co bid 19 to people harsh
realities in countries with the worst
outbreaks and drying up a survival plan
the precarious future of museums beyond
the pandemic
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
as parts of the country continue to lift
Public Health restrictions and more
people begin to gather in shops and on
public transit there is new guidance
tonight from Canada's chief Public
Health Officer about masks dr. Teresa
Tam now recommends wearing a non-medical
mask in situations where physical
distancing is not possible when we got
more evidence about asymptomatic and
pre-symptomatic individuals and that
although we don't fully understand their
role in transmission it is an added
layer of protection even for people who
don't have symptoms to wear masks to
prevent transmission to others Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau took the advice
today wearing a mask as he was driven to
Parliament Hill for an in-person sitting
of the House of Commons non-medical
masks are recommended not mandatory as a
way of protecting others from you public
health officials stress they are not a
substitute for hand-washing and physical
distancing which are still the best ways
to protect yourself from infection and
though restrictions are beginning to
ease the virus has not gone away it's
still out there and a second wave of
infections is possible some say even
likely even in places like Nova Scotia
which reported only one new case today
they heard lots of people saying one of
the pandemics / wave one is coming to an
end that's very different than the
pandemic is over so it's important that
we continue to follow the public health
rules even as we enter the recovery
phase provinces are making decisions
about how to reopen based on the number
of new kovat 19 cases trending downward
there are regional differences of course
but overall there have been fewer than
1,200 daily new cases reported across
Canada for the past four days in a row
the curve has flattened in most places
eight provinces and territories are
reporting just one or no new cases for
at least two days now Ontario and Quebec
have a distance to go there's good news
in Quebec though new case numbers there
dropped below 600 for the second day in
a row with 500 and
new cases reported today Ontario had 390
new cases down from yesterday but daily
new case numbers did dip below 300
earlier this month
reopening the economy means many people
are going back to work and if you have
young children with no child care or
school to send them to it is a tricky
juggling act
Michael Couture reports as provinces try
to get their economies back up and
flying again many parents like Sharif
machmood face the childcare conundrum
he's expected to be at the office at
least a few days a week but schools and
daycares are still closed I might have
to go to the office sometimes and then
and then my wife would watch the kids
and then alternatively like she might
have to go to the office or have
meetings and then I would stay home with
the kids and work from home but not
everyone has that flexibility and it's
exposing the importance of child care in
this country Global News has confirmed
Social Development Minister Ahmed Huson
is looking at ways of providing
provinces with more money for childcare
on an annual basis the prime minister
noted it was a campaign promise and is
now more pressing because of the
pandemic we made more commitments on
child care of working with the provinces
to invest in programs that will help
more parents more families and grow our
economies and our communities we need to
continue to do that particularly right
now and we will be there to work with
the provinces as we reopen and respond
to child care needs the penny has
dropped for a lot of people who weren't
paying enough attention child care
policy expert dr. Susan Prentiss says
now that politicians are paying
attention Canada needs to create a
national childcare system something the
Royal Commission on the status of women
recommended 50 years ago if I can be
blunt it's mainly men doing decision
making and I think that that's a long
history of politicians thinking
childcare is just a private family
responsibility without the return of
childcare in most provinces families are
on their own to juggle their jobs and
their children and many parents say it's
difficult to look too far down the road
without knowing who will care for their
kids right now without without the
support resources it's it's it's almost
impossible for parents to return to the
office full-time something governments
need to consider as the attempt to
relaunch their economies Mike lacouture
Global News Ottawa in Manitoba which
reported no new cases today some things
are opening up sooner than was first
planned starting on Friday groups up to
25 will be able to gather in doors and
groups of up to 50 people will be able
to get together outdoors plans are also
underway to allow limited outdoor visits
at personal care homes which will be a
relief for those who have been unable to
visit loved ones for more than two
months now protocols on how that will
work are still being put into place and
to help get costs under control the
Manitoba government is asking employees
to take five unpaid days off work by
next April in a memo to workers the
Central Services Minister says more than
6,000 public servants from the Deputy
Minister level down would be affected
but not essential employees delivering
pandemic services the province says the
proposal which needs union approval
would save 9.5 million dollars Premier
Brian Pallister is taking a 25 percent
pay cut big businesses can now apply for
emergency federal loans the large
employers emergency financing facility
or leaf is open to companies in all
sectors that generate more than 300
million dollars in revenue annually
businesses must be looking for financing
of 60 million dollars or more there are
conditions attached and no portion of
the loan is forgivable
many small businesses are also desperate
for help and fear they're on the verge
of eviction
David akin is looking at the federal
rent subsidy program tonight David well
Donna applications will open for the
commercial rent relief program on May
the 25th and relief will be available
retro actively for April and for Maine
can't be had for June but only landlords
not tenants can apply for rent relief
landlords can get a forgivable loan
worth 50 percent of a tenants rent the
tenant will have to pay 25 percent and
the landlord will have to cover the rest
but many
landlords say they will not apply for a
program that would essentially commit
them to writing off 25% of a tenants
rent well now go on to mr. C back during
a virtual meeting of MPs conservative
Kyle C back read an email he received
from a landlord
why do I have to apply it's not my
problem the tenant needs to pay si back
and others say the relief should go
directly to the tenant by putting all of
the burden on the landlord or all of the
privilege on the landlord whether they
choose to apply for this rent subsidy or
not they are putting small businesses in
this country in serious jeopardy the
Canadian Federation of Independent
Business surveyed their small business
members half said they will not make the
June rent and 1/5 now fear eviction
don't have the help they need who are
struggling to hang on and this is
make-or-break but Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau says landlords should get with
the program
landlords need to be a part of the
solution on this we need them to
understand that they do have a deep
vested interest in keeping their renters
in those spaces Ontario's premier too
had a message for landlords nothing
drives me more crazy than greedy
landlords taking advantage of people and
small business owners that are just
trying to keep their head above water
now Ford's comment might be a popular
one but business groups have been saying
for weeks now that premiers and
provincial governments need to do more
to help save businesses on Main streets
around the country Donna
David akin in Ottawa thanks members of a
mohawk community in Quebec have blocked
access to a provincial park that was set
to partially reopen today the road leads
into
Provincial Park northwest of Montreal
grand chief and nearby Gannett Satake
urged premier fresh well ago to keep the
park closed
he says trails lead directly into the
community and visitors could expose
residents to the coronavirus there are
now more than 5 million confirmed cases
of Cove in 19 the world more than 1.5
million of them are in the u.s. the
number one country for Kovach 19 Russia
is now in second place with just over
three hundred and eight thousand cases
and Brazil is in third with more than
270,000 confirmed cases its daily death
toll keeps rising to the country's
health system is teetering on the brink
of collapse brazil's president though is
dismissing concerns and his Eric
Sorenson explains he's advocating the
use of hydroxychloroquine the same drug
President Trump says he is taking Brazil
is rapidly becoming ground zero for the
coronavirus outlying areas don't have
intensive care beds some patients are
being airlifted hospitals are reportedly
on the brink of being overwhelmed and
yet on sunday brazil's president balsa
Niro posed with crowds that were crammed
together the government has supported
treatments at Ballston aero we hope soon
will be free of the issue
congratulations to us all but Brazil has
seen its highest kovat 19 numbers just
this week
in daily confirmed cases Brazil is over
17,000 right behind the United States at
close to 20,000 Russia is reporting
9,000 cases per day India a little over
5,000 obviously population makes a
difference Canada is in a group of among
10 countries at over 1,000 daily cases
now this is the global picture of the
daily confirmed deaths Canada among a
group of countries with between 50 and
250 deaths per day Mexico has jumped
above 250 the UK has moved back above
500 Brazil is consistently above 500
deaths per day and the United States
still averaging more than 1,000 deaths
per day and these are some of the
countries where the leaders have been
criticized for downplaying the
coronavirus in the early days we can
send a coronavirus packing critics say
Britain's Prime Minister failed to take
the virus seriously for too long then he
got the disease the Russian government
was accused of downplaying the disease
and American President Trump suggested
the first u.s. case numbers would go
down not up within a couple of days is
going to be down to close to 0 now the
US Russia and Brazil have the most
confirmed cases in the world
to have a coordinated nationwide
approach to public health restrictions
Brazil is a-brewing formula for
catastrophe bolts and arrow supporters
in crowded protests defying the virus
amid some of the most densely populated
cities in the world Paulson arrow is
seen as Latin America's Donald Trump and
yet Trump is now considering a travel
ban on Brazil now Brazil is having some
trouble no question about it
a stark image mass grave sites in Brazil
one emergency official says bluntly
we're losing the battle against the
virus Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto
the woman who died in the crash of a
snowbirds jet on Sunday was remembered
in Halifax today at the navy dock yard a
spokesperson for the Canadian Armed
Forces read a statement on behalf of
captain Jen Casey's family they say
their daughter died supporting an
important mission that seemed to be
designed for her operation inspiration
is a mission with one focus
making Canadians happy in a time of
uncertainty and there was no one better
no better person in this world to carry
out that mission than Jen her beautiful
smile and positively infectious
personality could brighten anyone's day
KC grew up in Halifax she worked as a
journalist before starting in a career
as a public affairs officer for the
snowbirds the 35 year olds family says
Nova Scotia will be their daughter's
final resting place the jet she was in
crashed shortly after takeoff on Sunday
in Kamloops BC the snowbirds had been on
a cross-country tour to raise Canadian
spirits during the Cova 19 pandemic an
emergency on top of the pandemic coming
up what triggered the floods ravaging
parts of Michigan
plus a new regal honor for captain Tom
Moore disaster in Michigan two dams have
burst causing catastrophic flooding in
the central part of the state about
11,000 people have been told to flee
their homes the city of Midland could
soon be under more than 2 and 1/2 meters
of water it is the worst flooding in
years to go through this in the midst of
a global pandemic is almost unthinkable
continue to wear a face covering when
you go to a shelter or go stay with a
friend or relative please try to protect
yourself if you are able the flooding
follows days of heavy rain across the
u.s. Midwest there's also been
widespread flooding in Illinois Ohio and
other states the u.s. is getting closer
to business as usual
all 50 states have now begun phasing in
plans to reopen and though the numbers
of new cases are dropping in some states
many have not met the federal criteria
of a 14 day downward trajectory of cases
as of Tuesday at least 17 states showed
an upward trend in average daily cases a
rise of at least 10 percent over the
previous seven days only 16 states had a
drop in new cases of 10% or more Jackson
prosecco reports as the US economy
sputters back to life the road
has never looked more uncertain just two
days after work resumed at a Ford plant
outside Chicago thousands of workers
were sent home and production was halted
after one employee tested positive for
kovat 19 social distancing really that
really doesn't work all 50 states are
pressing ahead with full or partial
reopening
there's nervousness about what will
happen next as people return to stores
and malls I feel like as long as we
follow the guidelines that are out then
we'll be ok president Trump continues to
project confidence as he champions the
economy tweeting that the g7 summit
called off due to the pandemic should
take place as originally scheduled in
early June at Camp David a great sign to
all normalization so yes we need to keep
meeting as leaders whether that's
virtual in-person will certainly take a
look at what the US is proposing safety
measures remain a contentious issue in
the u.s. in Michigan barbers and
stylists cut hair on the steps of the
State Capitol defying orders to stay
close all right don't come from the
government they come from God
simple as that while the Centers for
Disease Control is facing criticism over
60 pages of reopening guidelines they
were amended to remove any mention of
churches or religious institutions you
can't believe overly prescriptive not
every state in every county in every
jurisdiction has the same infection
infection rate the guidelines give a
glimpse of what the new normal may look
like across America with regular
temperature checks recommended for
teachers and students in schools and
restaurants told to use disposable
dishes to prevent customers from
spreading the virus as they slowly
reopen their doors
Jackson Cross Co Global News Washington
Antarctica going green is this the
beginning of a new ecosystem you are
watching global national more than 2
million people were told to flee their
homes to avoid it but cyclone anthem has
already killed at least 15 people as it
barreled into India and Bangladesh the
storm is the most powerful cyclone to
make landfall in the region in two
decades it's destroyed hundreds of homes
down trees and whipped up storm surges
along the coast climate change is
causing parts of Antarctica to turn
green warming temperatures are helping
with the formation and spread of algae
blooms new research shows it's become so
prolific in some places it's now visible
from space scientists have created the
first-ever large-scale map of the algae
and think it could potentially create a
source of nutrition for other species
and could form a new ecosystem they
believe the algae will keep spreading as
global temperatures increase collection
of closures next the struggle to
preserve museums in a pandemic
I think Sir Thomas sounds within us but
they are inside hub change humble as
always captain Tom war has already been
made an honorary colonel is now going to
be knighted by the Queen the veteran
raised more than 33 million pounds for
Britain's National Health Service by
walking 100 laps in his garden before
his 100th birthday the Queen was one of
thousands who sent him best wishes never
ever in the world would anticipate that
I would ever be knotted you know it just
didn't enter my head that it would but
it has on Twitter he said I'm absolutely
overwhelmed never for one moment could I
have imagined I would be awarded with
such a great honour I'd like to thank
Her Majesty the Queen
the Prime Minister and the great British
public I will remain at your service his
spirit is inspirational but it's the
money he's raised that will really make
a difference museums could use a
benefactor right now too they rely on
people it's what they're designed for
but because of the pandemic UNESCO the
UN cultural body says one in eight of
the world's museums could close
permanently Redman Shannon takes a look
at how some are coping hoping they have
a future
UNESCO says 85,000 museums worldwide
have been forced to close during the
covert 19 pandemic for those that have
reopened the do not touch signs have
taken on a whole new meaning
although physical distancing doesn't
seem to be a big issue just yet walking
up the big staircase there's nobody so
it's a strange call most eerie
experience and a far from relaxing
experience for visitors or staff our
financial losses are catastrophic saz a
spokeswoman for Belgium's Museum of Fine
Arts many museums struggle to make ends
meet at the best of times and after two
months without revenue they now need to
heavily limit visitor numbers this
exhibition marking 500 years since the
death of Raphael reopens in June
we will be organizing small groups of
around six people will be will be
welcomed by God which will be a sort of
shot on Canadians who've come to London
will know the National Gallery opposite
Canada house in Trafalgar Square
like many London museums and galleries
it doesn't charge for entry but it still
relies heavily on suggested donations
its cafes and gift shops we quickly
realized that we were in effect that no
longer a physical gallery we've become
an online gallery the detailed website
has been a way to welcome virtual
visitors but it's never quite the same
one of the things about going to mere
museum is you know you stand in front of
a picture it has a sort of physical
relationship of scale with your body
getting those bodies in front of
exhibits as soon as possible will be key
to keeping museums afloat Redman Shannon
Global News London and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen we leave you tonight with Canada
Post's newest stamp commemorating a
century of radio in our country on this
day in 1920 members of the Royal Society
of Canada gathered in Ottawa to hear the
first wireless broadcast soprano
Dorothy Lutton performing live in
Montreal within two years 34 radio
stations were operating across the
country thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]